after a massive wave of new players fall
guy's ultimate knockout has had some
wild moments in its first few months
let's go over some of the funniest
moments we've found number 10
dino bean goes extinct we see user co
and vit
following a very brave dinosaur beam but
as the dyno uncovers the last few tiles
he accidentally takes one for the team
in the process
thank you brave dino bean thank you
number nine when your luck runs out user
guerrillas shows us that rng can be a
fickle fiend
blessing him with all the right doors
then taking it all away
space the final frontier
number eight the juke out user i chain
makes a risky move
using the herd mentality to his
advantage to take out a big chunk of the
lobby
number seven woo-woo and lose for ready
user barn bundle
one woo-woo cost him the game was it
worth it
[Music]
maybe
number six case of the mondays user math
coupes proves that sometimes
the fall guys universe is just out to
get you and you can't do much about it
[Music]
number five go on without me user fancy
rancy shows that he's willing to take
one for the team
and hold back the griefers for others to
have fun ironically his efforts put him
right in the way of everyone who's
trying to have fun
number four griefer gets griefed you've
seen it before
there's always one griefer waiting to
ruin your day at the finish line
user galaxy taker said not today
help me help
[Music]
number three ninja air walk reddit user
rebooted blaze has got the ability to
double jump and fall guys
maybe it's because of the ninja outfit
number two crowd surfing user anarint
here doesn't have to be first place to
be king
he's seen here being carried by his
faithful servants
[Music]
number one the pinball technique
sometimes you're just along for the ride
and the nomad here takes full advantage
of that phrase
[Music]
for a game so simple fall guys ultimate
knockout continues to surprise us almost
daily with its funny moments
share your fall guys stories with us in
the comments below thanks for watching
you